I'm dressed up why because spider-man
homecoming why else would I be dressed
up now spider-man spider-man homecoming
trailer has hit us in fact by new I mean
first because the only spider-man
homecoming trailer we have and it starts
out pretty rabi's guys are robbing a
bank so you look like Dark Knight but
they're all dressed they have their
Avengers masks on he's like you're not a
Avengers and he's just like waste of all
because he's spider-man really what I
love about this trailer is it does give
the vibe of one of those hues ish movies
where there's kids in school and he's
dorky and he's nerdy and he's trying to
find his place we all love that it's
like edge of seventeen uh by the way
he's a superhero you see the vibe of it
I'm like yep that's why I love
spider-man and there were some people
out there would scare like well is Tony
Stark going to eclipse the fact this is
a spider-man movie it looks like Tony
Stark is straight-up support coolest
Alfred ever I'm just sayin Peter
Parker's like how do you become an
Avenger and Tony Stark's like just don't
do what I would do and don't do what I
wouldn't do somewhere in there's a great
area and he leans over and Peter Parker
thinks he's hugging us a Peter Parker
hugs if he's like I'm just getting the
dark basically get the [ __ ] out a world
of getting hits on YouTube puppies thank
you buddy I do love that Peter Parker
has a friend who knows he's spider-man
like out the kid this dude comes home
and he's like you're the spider is like
no not as far as a concert of he's like
you were bought the ceiling don't build
up this not like his friends gonna find
out in movie two or three now this dude
knows because Peter Parker needs support
because he can have someone to riff off
of when Tony Stark frustrates his kid
he's like I treat me like a kid and so
he has his his cohort cuz we all had
that friend man that friend who knew all
our secrets gotta have that friend who
knows where you stash your Spidey suit
Spidey's soon and Michael Keaton has
vulture is like don't mess with Mira
kill you at little juice but I love
Michael Keaton and his great villain the
best spider-man movies out there are the
ones that take a shitty dorky-ass
villain and make him cool Doc Ock is not
a cool villain I don't know what to say
when I was like he's the villain in the
second that's gonna be stupid I love the
first movie but are you serious and I
saw the trailer and he just smacks this
cab and the cab flips up I was like Doc
Ock Mike might be cool and this one the
vultures the same ways like the vulture
comes Dave ultra looks like he's gonna
totally wreck which really make
Sansa's too wide Tony Stark upgrade
spider-man suit and gives him the
webbing that I guess he's gonna glide
with if you really look at it that's not
enough to glide I feel like he's going
to hit the ground really slightly
alright I pathetically in a world where
Captain America's shield does not obey
the laws of physical say the webbing can
make him glide and he's doing that
because he's going up against a flying
villain who actually looks like he's
going to be cool the vulture has always
been a dorky as felon except in this
movie where he looks cool so hey this
give it I love this it really showed me
what I love about spider-man he's a kid
he's in high school he's dealing with
high school high school is very volatile
weird place you're trying to find your
place you have this mentor all right
this is where it gets a little out of my
league he has a mentor who you really
looks up to and he's like I don't worry
kid I'll pat you on the head and the
Avengers will deal with the vulture
problem it's fine for some reason they
don't because spider-man does and
spider-man sees it as a way for him to
prove himself to Tony Stark in the
Avengers really it's a great first
trailer I couldn't ask for this trailer
to give me anything other than what this
trailer gave me spider-man let nerds
know that it was ok to be a nerd and
even nerds or heroes I love that I love
this trailer I want to know what you
think about it so the spider-man
homecoming trailer have you seen it
whatever you thought about it comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]